pero no me en france 24 ya sea conmigo
en el estudio daniel hablando con
daniela buena noche bienvenida
comenzamos el fondo monetario
internacional- mejoró hoy sus
perspectivas económicas para este año
2020 cerraron muy buenas noches mire el
fondo celebra esta semana de manera
virtual su tradición a la asamblea
general conjunta con el banco mundial el
organismo estima que el kobe de 19 hará
que el pp mundial caiga 4,4 por ciento
este año eso quiere decir que tendrá un
impacto 44 veces superior a la crisis de
2008 cuando la economía global bajó 0,1
por ciento algunas de las claves de este
informe raúl son por ejemplo primero que
china será la única gran economía del
mundo con crecimiento positivo este año
por otro lado para américa latina y el
caribe pronostica un desplome del 8 1
por ciento y también cree que volverá a
niveles pre pandémicos o sólo hasta 2023
escuchemos sus crisis la crisis está
lejos de terminar el empleo se mantiene
muy por debajo de los niveles pre
pandémicos y el mercado laboral se ha
polarizado más
trabajadores de bajos ingresos los
pobres se están volviendo más pobres y
se espera que cerca de 90 millones de
personas caigan en la pobreza extrema
este año para ver si justicia
daniela y nosotros continuamos con más
noticias porque hay un nuevo capítulo en
la guerra comercial entre eeuu y la
unión europea sí señor la organización
mundial del comercio dio luz verde a
bruselas para que imponga aranceles a
importaciones por 4 mil millones de
dólares anuales desde eeuu esto como
parte de la guerra comercial que los
enfrenta desde hace 16 años por
subsidios aéreos
washington dicen que hervás los recibió
de manera ilegal pero a bruselas dice lo
contrario que fue boing el que se
benefició en una decisión similar el año
pasado lado demencia autorizó a la casa
blanca para imponer aranceles por 7.500
millones de dólares y lo hizo con varios
productos como aceite de oliva aceitunas
vinos whiskies entre otros raúl que ya
tienen arancel pero ahora en lugar de
prolongar más la guerra pues bruselas y
washington decidieron
negociar estos puntos la oficina
comercial de eeuu dijo que están
decididos a encontrar una solución a
esta disputa que aborde los subsidios
masivos que los gobiernos europeos han
proporcionado a hervás así como el daño
a los trabajadores de empresas
estadounidenses
daniela y esta semana es decisiva para
el éxito sí señor muy decisiva porque
este martes hubo un encuentro de
representantes europeos y el jueves
inicia una cumbre de dos días de la que
se espera por lo menos un principio de
acuerdo comercial post exit y como no
hay nada negociado todavía las
posibilidades de que el reino unido-
salga del bloque comunitario de manera
abrupta son cada vez mayores todo
dependerá de que ambas partes estén
dispuestas a hacer sacrificios
escuchemos se empieza a ver una cierta
flexibilización de la posición británica
en materia de ayudas estados también un
mecanismo de solución de controversias
también en gobernanza e incluso en pesca
se atisba
un principio de acercamiento de
posiciones aunque sigue siendo un
dossier en el que todavía es mucho lo
que separa a la unión europea del reino
unido- bueno daniela y hoy entra en
vigencia la nueva ley de teletrabajo en
españa bueno eso fue una ley que la
aprobaron el pasado 22 de septiembre
después de negociar con las patronales y
con los sindicatos la ley de trabajo a
distancia dice que las empresas deben
firmar un acuerdo con el empleado que
vaya a trabajar a distancia más del 30
por ciento de la jornada semanal durante
al menos tres meses en este acuerdo debe
comprometerse a pagar los gastos en que
pueda incurrir el trabajador además
tendrán que plasmar esa regulación en un
acuerdo colectivo con su planta de
personal en un plazo de hasta tres años
allí deberán ponerse de acuerdo en cómo
van a compensar esos gastos raúl manera
indicadores o stay de cerros en rojo en
una sesión en la que todavía no está
claro si habrá un segundo paquete de
estímulos económicos o no en europa
mercados como londres y parís están
reaccionando negativamente al
endurecimiento de restricciones
américa latina hubo resultados mixtos
impulsados por la bolsa de sao paulo
para finalizar la que nos tiene hoy como
cifra el día bueno este hablaba del
iphone 12 que se lanzó hoy pues entre
699 dólares y 1099 dólares cuesta este
iphone 2 el lanzado este martes por
dependiendo por supuesto del tamaño y de
la versión el anuncio y eso que es la
acción cayera casi 3 por ciento en
extracción de agua daniela como siempre
gracias por toda la información
económica ustedes también gracias
continuar con nosotros y buena noche